this is the moment Francisco oropeza was
led away in handcuffs ending a
nationwide manhunt authorities say a
call to an FBI tip line LED them to a
home in the nearby town of Cut and Shoot
Texas the arrest happened about 16 miles
from Cleveland Texas where the 38 year
old is accused of going to his
neighbor's home and killing five people
with an AR style rifle Friday night
before fleeing On The Run for the last
four days he was caught hiding
in a closet underneath some laundry they
effectively made the arrest he is
uninjured bottom line is we now have
this man in custody authorities say the
incident happened after
afternoon his gun in his yard because
the baby was
nine-year-old son were killed the boy
was the youngest of the victims all from
Honduras officials say they hope the
arrest will give closure to their loved
ones